alors on a donc effectivement plusieurs
témoignages une vingtaine selon médias
dans demain dans le l'article de
mediapart qui corrobore en fait tous les
propos de fanny agostini qui développe
notamment tout ce que tout ce qu'on
savait du de la première plainte
puisqu'elle a étayé sa plainte le 25
janvier dernier elle raconte vraiment
dans le démontage de raincourt elle
raconte notamment que dès 2009 alors
qu'elle avait 20 ans et que l été elle
avait son premier boulot
matinale de rmc que jean jacques bourdin
s'en est pris violemment à lui raconter
ce qu'elle dit est dit juste avant de
prendre l'antenne il m'a arraché la
feuille en disant qu'il n'y avait pas de
notes chez lui évidemment je n'avais pas
appris le bulletin parker j'étais
complètement démuni je me suis mise à
bredouiller et inventer des températures
quand la pub est arrivé il a crié dans
la rédaction elle est nulle je ne veut
plus d'elle chez moi je suis partie
pleurer dans une petite cabine sa salle
et sa chute d'accord est là je suis
d'accord alors je vous dis non mais
c'est un truc que j'aurais pu comme ça
mais j'aurais aimé dans sur quoi je veux
ça vous auriez pas fait cette démarche
semble non mais non
il m'arrive il m'arrive de gueuler sur
la mesure
de dire elle est nul je ne veux pas si
cela remet mais
c'est bien l'arctique est très
intéressant mais là pour le coup ça
devient compliqué mais alors il est
temps simon ammann rond quand on est
responsable d'une matinale quand on a
des grosses pressions parfois ouais on
peut être exigeant avec ses équipes à la
lutte
avec le stade à sa me ça me choque pas
plus que ça va guyomard bon mais quel
rapport avec une agression sexuelle on
va et venir mais d'accord mais qu'on
voit ce genre doivent toit en quoi ce
genre d'histoire puis le fait que c'est
un agresseur sexuel samia ghali qui est
très importante c'est des violences
sexuelles faites aux femmes et on la
décrédibilise avec des témoignages qui
se veulent choc qui n'ont rien de
choquant il n'y a rien de choquant là
dedans le témoignage on pourra parler
après mais l'histoire du maillot de bain
enfin de l'ombre en parle voilà et il
faut dire aussi dans le papier de
médiapart quand on le lit en entier il
ya beaucoup de témoignages qui disent
que jean jacques bourdin avait un
comportement qui était absolument pas
choquant c'est avec les femmes donc ça
il faut le dire aussi el aouina n'y a
qu'une agression sexuelle c'est avec
fanny agostini dans la piscine les
autres mariages tentative non pas toi
toi type d'agression sexuelle les aux
témoignages moi j'ai eu sidonie bonnec
je connais très bien
la personne qui est dénommée julie mais
qui ne sais pas ce n'est pas sa vraie
identité c'est une très bonne amie à moi
qui m'ont raconté les choses et qui ont
été pour elle perçue de façon violente
mais elles ne sont pas là pour dire
qu'elles ont été agressés sexuellement
mais pour corroborer alors mettez moi je
vous racontais les deux histoires de
famille à goscinny et de sidonie bonnec
donc pendant des années elle en a pleuré
elle était terrifiée feu négocié par le
journaliste elle a évité dans les
couloirs à tous elle raconte ensuite
chauffer le épisode de l'open de paix
tant de calvi en corse où elle s'était
rendue sur demande du pdg du groupe
alain weil c'est là qu'ils auraient eu
lieu la présumée agression sexuelle
avant le départ l'animateur de rmc lui
aurait proposé de faire la paix autour
d'un café à l'hôtel parisien le lutetia
il me flatte me dit qu'il est très fier
de moi qu'il a eu raison d'être brutal à
mes débuts cas ça m'a boosté alors que
pour moi c'était des moments douloureux
ensuite on en apprend plus dans cet
article sur la relation entre fanny et
goscinny et jean-jacques bourdin c'est
derrière la première fois que la jeune
femme accepte de parler de cette affaire
dans la presse elle a dit qu'elle ne
parlerait cas médiapart c'est ce qu'elle
a dit aujourd'hui sur son compte twitter
a raconté qu'en 2009 voilà donc il avait
il avait laissé ça et pendant concours
de pétanque jean jacques bourdin se
serait rapproché d'elle lui donnant des
conseils de retour à l'hôtel et le elle
relate avoir flipper en voyant
l'animateur avachi dans un canapé fumant
un cigare l'art garni d'une manière qui
me l'avait donc il avait je l'avais
jamais regardé avant là ma peur a changé
de nature je me suis sentie cible est
mal à l'aise au point de ne pas aller
dîner ensuite elle revient ensuite oui
guillaume mais oui enfin non c'est pas
une armée attendez on arrive là et elle
revient sur la présumée agression
sexuelle dans la piscine de l'hôtel
lendemain matin il s'est mis à nager
parallèlement à moi tout en commençant à
me faire des compliments me dire que
j'avais changé qu'il ne voyait pas comme
ça j'étais hyper mal à l'aise l'estomac
serré l'animateur se serait rapproché
très rapidement et l'aurait attrapée par
le cou sur le côté et l'aurait attiré
vers lui brusquement en essayant de
l'embrasser à plusieurs reprises elle
raconte avoir été complètement prise de
court en avoir pas crier mais s'être
débattu être parvenu à sortir de l'eau
c'est là qu'aurait prononcée et qu'il
aurait prononcé sa fameuse phrase
j'obtiens toujours ce que je veux une
phrase qui a ponctué ses cauchemars
pendant des années et qu'elle a vécue
comme une menace de la part de quelqu'un
qui avait un ascendant aux hiérarchies
sur elle voilà après le raconte anna va
voir exister en parler alors sur la
sphère famille a beau signer après on va
parler de la sphère sidonie bonnec et ce
qui s'est passé avec sidonie oui non
mais les problèmes de cet article c'est
que ça mélange énormément de choses ça
mélange du harcèlement moral ça mélange
effectivement une tentative d'agression
sexuelle ça mélange harcèlement d'un
supérieur hiérarchique
donc tout est mis au même plan et c'est
ça le souci parce que et une agression
sexuelle c'est pas de la même nature
qu'une agression d'un supérieur
hiérarchique ou de harcèlement moral ou
d'un mec qui est lourd parce qu'on est
en fait on dresse une sorte de portrait
et en même temps et voilà il ya mis à
part par fanny agostini qui et
circonstanciée le reste c'est alors on
en a dit comment va en parler après là
on est sûr fans et sur fanni à goscinny
il ya visiblement une tentative
d'agression sexuelle mais ça m'a dit
mais morale alors meriam myriam donc il
y à des révélations chaque semaine sur
la sphère bodin's qui ad'autres choses
qui m'en sortir pour l'instant il ya
peut-être une nouvelle plainte qui
devrait qui devrait arriver ça un peu
compliqué parce que la personne ne vit
pas en france d'accord est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres personnalités de la télé qui
peuvent parler dans les prochains jours
ou pas du tout on n'a pas connaissance
n'aurait il y en aurait une personnalité
de la télé delà de la radio il ya
prescription jacques saint jean se
ferait sur le débat sur la plante qui
pourrait être déposée il n'ya pas
prescription